la cina ha smesso
no
lo scrive
agi
quel testo
cc
la scena
maschi
cc
ah ecco
mg
mi fa massa no è che
ho
mai capito
beh
no
insomma
lo stesso
giorni mistero
certo
lo show
giusto
no
si no
presi
non c'è
davis
sisma
bravissima
grazie allora lei e gaia elisa rossi
forse a questo punto non ci stupisce
tanto quello che dirò è stato da poco
nominata campionessa italiana di magia
e oltre a questo
ci tengo anche a sottolineare che è la
prima donna a ricevere questo premio
grazie
ma gaia scusa
quanti anni hai
ho 13 anni
però
allora mi chiedo questa è una grande
passione sei molto giovane
vuoi raccontarci come quando è nata
allora i miei genitori sono però b dei
maghi e quindi io quando ero piccola li
vedevo nel salone di casa provare i loro
numeri dentro una scatola di giochi di
prestigio che mi faceva un po da boxe e
quindi fin da quando ero piccola sono
entrata in contatto con degli oggetti
che mi sono poi rimasti nel cuore e
quando mia madre mi chiese se volesse
essere un'attrice perché lei aveva
studiato teatro da giovane e mio padre
se vorreste essere una ballerina perché
lo aveva studiato danza io dissi che
volevo essere una maga
certo
ma immagino che insomma questa è una
passione piuttosto ingombrante ti
prenderà un sacco di tempo è un grosso
impegno come fai a mettere insieme
questo con quelli che sono gli impegni
di una ragazza di 13 anni quindi la
scuola lo studio gli amici allora mi
organizzo e quindi mi è stato sempre
insegnato fin da piccola che
l'organizzazione è fondamentale e
soprattutto la concentrazione perché si
devo studiare un tot di pagine faccio
quello è non rispondi messaggi piuttosto
che se devo fare magia non mi metto dire
e non ci riesco non soltanto lì a
lamentarmi ma lavoro sodo è quindi
insomma organizzazione e concentrazione
benissimo adesso un'ultima domanda io ho
letto sul tuo sito internet che ti
definisci cacciatrice di sogni
cosa cosa significa per te mi definisco
cacciatrice di sogni perché come gli
animali quando vanno a caccia uscito un
sogno
lo seguono lo inseguono e lo afferrano
così io più dei sogni li seguo ti seguo
e via ferro
va bene allora grazie e in bocca al lupo
per un magico futuro grazie mille a voi
ciao